[Music]
good morning Hank it's Thursday remember
this guy
it's all starting to come full circle
all right Hank I tried shooting outside
but I just couldn't get into it I mean
it's a beautiful day outside but no
matter how beautiful it is outside it's
always just a little bit more beautiful
inside Hank I want to thank you for
reminding me in your awesome video
yesterday the nerd fighting isn't about
tearing people asunder it's about
bringing people together although I do
have one question about yesterday's
video Hank have you seen your still shot
Wow Hank if that still frame were in a
museum and it should be I wonder what
the title of the photograph would be boy
with Smurf fetish impersonates chipmunk
the blue-lipped possum once it's dinner
bucktooth mcgee has seen the face of the
lord frankly the possibilities are
endless by the way Hank speaking of
nerdfighting a few commenters have been
asking whether or not nerdfighters fight
for or against nerds you know they'll be
like stain fighters don't fight for
stains and of course I don't want people
to think that we're fighting against
nerds although I mean to look at either
of us it would be very difficult to
conclude that we're fighting against
nerds unless we're masochists I mean we
were born with nerdy faces nerdy faces
they're already faces we were born with
nerdy faces because our parents are
nerds right I forgot about how I'm
supposed to leave the same to you but
anyway Hank this has been causing me a
lot of anxiety for the last few weeks
because every time I wear my nerdfighter
shirt out on the town I'm like maybe
people think that I'm fighting against
nerds but then I was like wait a second
do freedom fighters fight against
freedom and for that matter do Power
Rangers range against power no of course
not they range for power wait do they
range for power what does power ranger
mean doesn't mean that they're Rangers
of power or Rangers with power or
Rangers in favor of power oh god I'm
getting confused again nerdfighters are
for nerds Hank that's all we need to
know Oh Hank incidentally a nerdfighter
recently pointed out to me that there's
a challenge that I gave myself that I
tried to complete and failed to complete
I am referring of course to the eat five
sheets of toilet paper while discussing
the political situation in Nepal
challenge Hank I gave myself that
challenge on January 2nd and as you will
probably recall I succeeded in talking
about the political situation in Nepal
but I failed at eating the five sheets
of toilet paper while doing it so Hank
hear me now and believe
in two days on Friday I am going to eat
five whole sheets of toilet paper while
discussing the political situation in
Nepal because that's what Brotherhood
2.0 is really about Hank it's about
welcoming people in while you and I
discuss the things that really matter to
us like you know the political situation
in Nepal and there's no better way to
welcome people in than to eat five
sheets of toilet paper while you're
doing it
or maybe that's just me I love to watch
people eat toilet paper anyway Hank
three other things that I want to
quickly discuss first kiva.org Hank as
you know for months the nerdfighters
have been supporting kiva.org a website
that allows you and me and regular
people to be microfinance ears and a
funny thing happened to kiva.org
recently they ran out of poor people
that's right Hank for a while kiva.org
became so popular because you know it's
all the fun of charity without having to
spend any money that there were actually
more people looking to donate money than
there were entrepreneurs in the
developing world looking to accept that
money and for a minute Hank I was like
wow nerdfighters cured poverty but it
turns out that there were actually more
poor people they just hadn't gotten them
up on the website yet but they're up
there now so now we can all go back and
start making loans at Kiva org also Hank
I saw in PC Magazine that eco geek org
your website was named one of the 100
best websites on the entire internet and
Hank I know how many websites there are
on the Internet there are like eight or
nine hundred third Hank secret siblings
Adam and Ava made a great movie that we
should all watch and then vote for and
breast cancer surviving nerdfighter Kim
Cline is up for a big scholarship you
can find more information about both of
those things here or possibly here and
there's always the slight possibility
that it's over there
thank you're a great brother I'll see
you tomorrow every time I say something
sentimental I'm all like but you are a
great brother